a man named Charlie stands on a stage in
front of a crowd of a few thousand
people he is receiving an Oscar for best
film director filled with nerves pride
in a mix of other unfamiliar emotions he
looks out at the crowd as they cheer for
him the cheer fades as he begins to say
thank you well first of all I want to
thank my mother and father for their
support through everything I want to
thank my wife Cara and my daughter
Olivia for the light and inspiration you
guys bring to my life
Charlie pauses for a second and looks
down flustered by the pressure to
remember everything that he wants to say
he quickly recovers and picks back up I
want to thank the entire cast and crew
you guys truly brought this film to life
and made it special and I couldn't have
done it without each and every one of
you lastly I want to thank my longtime
collaborator and best friend Nick I
believe we were just eight or nine when
we made our first film together and if I
remember correctly all things considered
he was pretty good
Nick's sitting in the front section of
the crowd smiles and laughs as he
lightly points his finger at Charlie and
a gesture of camaraderie I'll never
forget that experience Charlie goes on
with it changed my life forever and now
here I am living out the childhood dream
that formed that day and I couldn't be
more grateful
Charlie nods his head says thank you one
last time and holds up his award giving
it a little forward shake as if he is
cheering the crowd with it the crowd
applauds without knowing it Charlie had
just deceived every person in the
audience and the millions of people
watching on TV and anywhere else the
ceremony was being shown
not because he intentionally wanted to
enhance his speech or hide something in
his story or anything of the sort but
because when he said if I remember
correctly he in fact didn't rewind to
the day that Charlie referred to in his
speech the day that he credited his
introduction to filmmaking and his
childhood dream with the day he was
thinking of was Saturday March 26th 1988
Charlie and Nick were 10 years old
they were working on their first short
film together using Nick's father's VHS
camcorder Charlie filmed and directed
while Nick acted out an adventure
through the neighborhood pretending they
were racing against time trying to
rescue a girl who was captured by some
indiscriminate villains they casted
Nick's younger sister as the girl and
Nick's parents as the villains
improvising lines and scenes with them
then Nick and Charlie edited it all
together on the VHS player adding in
little glitch effects cuts music and so
on they premiered it to Nick's family
when they were done Nick's parents as
well as Nick's older brother told Nick
and Charlie how impressive it was not
just the obligatory compliment that
friends and family so often give each
other but they were actually impressed
at just 10 years old
Nick seemed rather comfortable on camera
and Charlie showed an impressive natural
understanding of cinematic timing angles
emotion scene blocking and so on the
only problem is it wasn't Charlie
Charlie was home with his parents that
Saturday when the film was made it was
Nick's other friend Steven who made the
film with Nick Charlie had nothing to do
with it four years later however when
Nick and Charlie were hanging out at
Charlie's house the night before
starting high school as friends
sometimes do especially before after
major chapters in life they were
reminiscing about memories together
throughout elementary and middle school
Charlie and Nick were best friends and
hung out with each other the most out of
everyone they knew this cause Nick to
simply mix up Charlie with Steven when
recalling his memory of making the film
when this mixed-up memory floated to the
surface of Nick's consciousness he
blurted it out hey you remember when we
made that short film together Nick asked
Charlie Charlie didn't remember at first
but considered that he had likely just
forgotten about it it sounded possible
enough he paused for a moment and then
said I think so I'm not sure if I
remember when was it seriously Nick
exclaimed surprised that Charlie forgot
it was like four or five years ago I
think 6th grade maybe was with my sister
and we had a whole plot to it it was
stupid but kind of sick Nick said he
reminded Charlie how good he was at
filming and directing it and how
impressed his parents and siblings were
with it he told Charlie how he
remembered Charlie being a natural at
the whole thing this made Charlie want
the memory to be real and he began to
convince himself that it likely was and
he had in fact just forgotten about it
nick seemed so sure about it and Charlie
trusted Nick oh yeah I remember now
Charlie exclaimed back to Nick
Charlie was still a little unsure when
he said this but was starting to find a
clear memory forming in his head which
was enough for him to believe that it
was real in this moment an entirely
false memory was planted in Charlie's
brain
Charlie was experiencing something
fairly common this occurrence happens
every day to any number of people a
memory is formed fabricated or edited in
addition to or in place of what really
happened in psychology it is known as a
confabulation or false memory understood
to be caused by
psychological occurrence is known as
memory conformity suggestibility source
misattribution or the misinformation
effect as well as other things generally
in all cases some cause like a social
influence individual desire misjudgment
emotional circumstance etc creates an
error in the memory retrieval process
and as a result a memory can end up
becoming modified or a false memory can
be planted in the brains memory Center
in 1995 a study found that when a
research conductor instructed a group of
individuals to recall and describe
specific childhood memories that were
given to the conductor by the
participants parents if three out of the
four memories were real but one was fake
and intentionally suggested to the
participant as real about 25% of the
participants believed that it was a real
memory and went on to describe it
vividly and emotionally in the first
study the suggested memory was that the
participant had gotten lost in a
shopping mall as a child and was rescued
by an elderly lady the study was then
followed by many other similar studies
which suggested more unusual memories
like almost drowning being attacked by
vicious animals witnessing satanic
possessions and so on in all cases a
statistically significant number between
33 and 50% of all participants agreed
that they had experienced the suggested
memory and recalled it as real even
though it wasn't furthermore the false
memory implantation is found to occur
most easily when participants are given
information from trustworthy individuals
Nick being charlie's best friend made
charlie naturally susceptible generally
a situation like this is benign and
doesn't change much if anything at all
most memories in general don't somehow
ever change everything as Charlie and
Nick began high school the seed of
Charlie's false memory started to sprout
causing Charlie to become increasingly
interested in film production Charlie
created film projects with Nick
participated in the school's TV station
film Club in the town's local TV network
because of Charlie's false memory
he believed he was already naturally
good at filming and directing and
editing which gave him the confidence to
take on lead roles and projects faced
tough challenges and take interesting
creative risks right off the bat Charlie
was comfortable in high-pressure roles
never doubting his intuition he soon
began working as a freelance filmmaker
with local companies and clients who
were looking for video advertising video
tutorials event coverage in whatever
else Charlie was really good
he was the most talented member in the
school's film club his short films were
impressive all things considered and his
clients were more than satisfied with
his work the false memory seemed to be
lining up with Charlie's actual
abilities in college Charlie and Nick
studied film at the same school
collaborating on several film projects
of which Charlie would write and direct
while Nick would help write and act in
two of which won multiple awards at
various film festivals as a means of
living Charlie also began to shoot and
direct music videos for friends and
friends moving with confidence to reach
project never doubting his abilities one
music video Charlie made was with an
artist who was becoming successful and
popular in the mainstream simultaneous
to working with Charlie because of this
timing and Charlie's unique bold
approach with the video the video took
off in the music world and Charlie began
working with other major music artists
soon after facilitating the start of his
professional career as he grew through
the music video world Charlie wrote
screenplays and pitches for feature
films determined to accomplish his
childhood dream of being a feature film
director several years later in 2004
Charlie's feature film directorial debut
was released as an independent film
entitled delusions of grandeur starring
Nick as the lead that year it won an
Independent Spirit Award for Best
Original Screenplay and with this
Charlie put a stake in Hollywood now 15
years later present-day here Charlie is
coming back down from the Dolby theater
stage holding an Oscar for Best Director
one of the highest public achievements
in all of film on the drive home after
the awards ceremony Charlie his wife his
parents Nick and a few other friends
talk about the surreal nough sup the
night Charlie's wife looks at him and
Nick and says this is unbelievable
did you guys ever think you would be
leaving the Dolby Theatre in a limo with
an Oscar Charlie smiles at her and then
looks at Nick for a brief moment before
answering then he says well I can't say
I ever knew for sure but I think you're
only as capable as you believe you are
some people aren't nearly as capable as
they believe they are some people are
far more and some people are exactly
right and you can only find out which
one you are by following it to the end I
guess I'm one of the lucky ones who was
right the small group in the limo
marvels at the profound sounding answer
unaware of the incredible and beauty
irony the entire basis of Charlie
success was founded on a false memory
something that he was wrong about
fortunately for Charlie he was right
about the fact that you are often only
as capable as you believe you are and
better yet perhaps sometimes you only
become capable because you believe you
are
[Music]
you
[Music]